ladies and gentlemen the next topic on
the agenda is the ftth Council Europe
award ceremony the ftth award is given
to an individual and to an operator that
have made an outstanding contribution to
FTTH adoption in Europe anyone can
contribute online so please don't forget
to nominate your champion next year and
the winners are selected by the board of
directors and by the committee chairs of
the ftth council europe for the first
time this year two companies receive the
ftth award trophy in recognition of
rolling out advanced fiber networks one
of our winners in the operator category
receives the ftth award in recognition
for its high investment in
state-of-the-art fiber optic networks at
the end of sep tember 2015 it counted
nearly 28,000 FTTH be subscribers and
reached a coverage of more than fifty
percent this is one of the highest in
Europe for an incumbent ladies and
gentlemen the ftth Council Europe
operator award is given to post
Luxembourg
so let me welcome onto the stage mr.
Gaston Berlin burger director of post
technologies and call my president Edgar
acha to present the trophy
many many thanks to the council to have
selected post lux book for this operator
what we are very very proud and honored
indeed in 1997 our company has made a
clear decision in favor of fiber 20
today more than fifty percent of our
households in Luxembourg are connected
with home Sang's lot to my stuff for
having achieved this challenge thank you
he stay close
thank you the joint winner of the ftth
operator award is an alternative
telecommunications operator and getting
deploying FTTH infrastructure since 2
2010 this operator has made an important
difference in the Polish FTTH market by
significantly growing its fiber networks
particularly in the greater poland
suburban and rural areas where FTTH can
greatly contribute to bridging the
digital divide ladies and gentlemen the
ftth council europe operator award is
given to polish alternative operator in
our and let me welcome on to the stage
mr. Mick I bug Kodiak board member and
CFO of NL
like this in gentlemen it's a great
honor and pleasure to be here with you
today first of all I would like to thank
you on behalf of enya for this great
award we are very pleased thank you to
the fth council to the president thank
you to the founders and shareholders of
in our group for the determination and
belief that this can happen thank you to
our clients that are using our broadband
services thank you to those introduced
individuals that built the network by
themselves just to connect to our
resources there are such a guys in the
world thank you to those that send us
complaint letters that day village was
not on the project map thanks to them we
know exactly why we do it we know that
our work is appreciated and is
meaningful finally we'll finally I would
like to thank you to our employees and
to the management team this is thanks to
them thanks to the creativity day energy
and their determination and believe that
we can change local communities any now
we believe that in a rapidly changing
environment in the word that is faster
and more complex than ever before we can
make a change by using FTTH technology
over the past few years in a half
connected 150,000 clients these are
households and companies we are
connecting hospitals local government
units we connect post offices and fire
and police stations and I am here to
prove that
ftth technologies really making a
difference is a game changer people have
equal access to information and
knowledge this is something new this
offered to people in rural areas and
this is exactly what we cared the most
in greater poland the region in air
comes from so i wish you all inspiring
and fruitful timing here and once again
thank you very much for this award
last but not least the winner of the
ftth individual award has been one of
Europe's most active defenders of FTTH
for more than a decade now he is one of
the founding leaders of the ftth Council
Europe elected president of the
organization from two thousand four to
two thousand seven and then directed
general from 2007 to November 2015 his
involvement in the ftth Council Europe
helped the organization to develop a
strong and respected voice in Europe our
winner is not the managing director of
new gig the largest rural FTTH network
in Austria it is a pleasure for me to
welcome him back onto the stage of the
ftth conference you will have guessed
that the ftth council europe individual
award is given to Professor how big taba
thank you Nadia ladies and gentlemen
well it's it's an emotional emotional
moment for me in the morning i was
thinking what a big stage and for the
first time I'm not standing on here now
I'm standing here back on the stage and
I can tell you it was a real great
challenge to lead the ftth counts in
Europe in the last 11 years we started
is a small group of companies with the
idea to accelerate fiber-to-the-home in
europe in two thousand four at a time
where other people said it will never
come we really were fighting for it and
today the organization has grown to one
of the largest industry bodies in europe
and this is really a great progress and
if i get devoured today this progress is
not just made by myself it was also made
by the board members by the companies
that were part of the ftth council in
the last 11 years and especially by the
team by you Nadia and by all the other
people working with me in the last 11
years that I wanted to sing and also
want to thank the board of directors for
this award but for the president it
means really a lot for me as a really
belief and I'm a believer you know it
that 50 to the home is the only
future-proof broadband solution and
Europe needs to deploy it as quick as
possible you know for 11 years I was
standing here and on many other stages I
was talking and explained to
policymakers decision-makers journalists
and many other stakeholders why fth is
important now in my new role as the CEO
of the largest ftth project in Austria I
will be able to prove what I promised in
the last 11 years thank you again for
this award and i'm happy to say i want
fiber and I build fiber thank you
you